on savait déjà que les services
funéraires au canada sont en pleine
mutation
mais la numérisation du monde des
vivants semble maintenant empiéter sur
la dignité des morts ce qui à nouveau au
plan des derniers adieux ce sont ces
égos portraits croqués sur le vif avec
grand maman encore avec la grande tente
en arrière-plan au visage qui est une
affaire qui enlève le sourire notamment
aux responsables des salons funéraires
du québec faut bien comprendre que la
pratique de prendre des photos avec leur
défense est propriétaire d'une maison
funéraire qui est bientôt centenaire
prévaut depuis la nuit des temps les
gens prennent des photos avec les
défunts le problème ou là la nouveauté
qu'on voit c'est la diffusion de ces
photos lomé place sur les réseaux
sociaux
denis desrochers et président de la
corporation des thanatologues du québec
qu'on appelait autrefois les croque
morts
il dénonce cette pratique qui causent
préjudice à la famille du défunt d'abord
c'est là que ça devient un peu plus
elite-1 et chacun pour certaines
familles qui n'ont pas donné
l'autorisation d'accès fait dans un
cadre respectueux et ligne avec
l'approbation de la famille
en ce qui nous concerne on voit pas
grand malaise ou même certains experts
s'entendent pour dire que ça peut être
bénéfique pour la famille de garder des
photos de leurs défunts le problème
encore une fois c'est quand on vit à la
division ou à la rude que la situation
là ça devient plus problématique et ça
peut porter préjudice à la famille et/ou
circonstances qu'on essaie d'établir
alentours de la dignité du défendent des
gens qui vont faire des photos loufoque
a cousu d'un défaut ils vont tenter pas
où je sais maintenant c'est facile pour
les gens dessous c'est là leur appareil
téléphonique dans leurs poches et de
prendre une photo à la dernière minute
avec dans une pulsion nous pour les -
irrespectueuse donc c'est ce type de
photos cause préjudice monsieur à la
famille c'est l'eau la polémique
alentours des seuls funéraire et l'eau
les égouts portrait au salon funéraire
sans autorisation des proches sont ils
des comportements morbide entièrement
déplacés ou ins une nouvelle façon de
s'exprimer
une nouvelle vision du dos
si ça doit passer par le céleri ou en
2017 parce que c'est comme ça maintenant
qu'on appelle ça s'est fait avec éthique
et professionnalisme si ça peut aider
quelqu'un à constater la réalité des
faits je pense que brigitte des chaînes
est un autolog est directrice générale à
la résidence funéraire du saguenay au
québec mais n'en sait comment on va
l'utiliser c'est quelqu'un qu'elle sorte
de photo on reprend des airs que ici
clair par exemple que je me dis faut que
la famille soit d'accord ou l'amant où
la personne mandataires non c'est dans
cet encadrement alors et non la lie du
côté de la loi on a de grands noms paul
bret vous savez tout le monde et l'on
leur téléphone dans leur poche quand
même qu'on voudra interdire ce genre de
choses a à mon sens une femme que sa
voix est impossible si on a fait une
utilisation bien encadré et sikhs et
professionnels je pense que ça peut
aider certaines personnes par ce qui
arrive que des c'est certainement une
étape importante que de voir la personne
c'est moi je mange peu paumé recrée
consommer évidemment je souhaiterais que
tu as fait dans des conditions
professionnelles se prendre en photo
avec la tour eiffel en arrière de soi ou
avec l'attenté stèle au salon funéraire
témoignait-il de la même intention lego
portrait ne serait pas en fait que
l'expression d'une société devenue hyper
narcissique légaux portrait serait en
fait le début d'une conversation un
signe du désir de communion or la
communion est un élément important dans
le deuil
vous avez eu avec ce beau au terme des
goths portrait qui est venu donc se
superposer à autoportrait andry gunther
est enseignant en histoire visuelle
il publiait récemment dans le nouvel
observateur une apologie du selphy quand
vous employez le mot selphy vous faites
déjà une qualification qui qui qui dit
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire autoportrait
auto ça veut dire je le fais moi-même
ego portrait sa fuite il s'est tourné
vers cet égoïste c'est tout en fait
c'est tout de suite une critique c'est
comme quand vous dites photos amateurs
voyez photo amateur l'amateur c'est pas
le professionnel donc ils maîtrisent pas
l'outil et c'est donc en fait il y a une
charge négative dans le terme dès le
départ et c'est en réalité cette charge
qui a fait émerger cette critique du
narcissisme qui si vous voulez et
fictives
les adolescentes sont pas plus narcisse
les adolescents sont narcissique et la
photo numérique n'a rien changé
voilà c'est pas un drame le cette fille
est une image sociale comme tout comme
toutes les photographies connectés ce
sont des images
autrement dit c'est un c'est quelque
chose que vous adresser à quelqu'un donc
envoyer une image c'est pas une fin en
soi ça ne s'arrête pas là contrairement
à la contemplation du tableau sur une
sur les cimaises une image sur un réseau
social c'est le début de quelque chose
le début d'une conversation où le milieu
ou si vous voulez mais on attend des
réponses étaient l'image devient un
outil d'échangé et d'interaction
un reportage de radio canada
international